[Musique]
la cft eu la compagnie foyalaise de
transport urbain est dans son caddie ce
matin avec son président alfred bonjour
bonjour monsieur viol tombe un jour aux
auditeurs de martinique la première une
énième agression de chauffeurs samedi
dernier un week end sans bus tout comme
le lundi jour de reprise de l'activité
économique après les jours gras combien
combien à l'alfred combien ça vous a
coûté se le dise en activité alors il
est difficile aujourd'hui de faire le
point précis de ces jo parce qu'en fait
il faut non seulement compter la halle à
comptabiliser la perte de recettes le
manque à gagner mais il faut
comptabiliser également toutes les
dépenses qui sont afférentes à la
situation du conducteur parce que un
conducteur qui s'est trouvé dans cette
situation que nous avons connue c'est à
dire piégés pendant de longues minutes
c'est un conducteur qui est abîmée ce
conducteur pour lequel il faut mobiliser
certains nombres le croyait il ya le
coût humain qui est extraordinaire et
j'ai envie de le dire
ces agressions qui se multiplient génère
dans le service public
un certain nombre de désagréments n'ont
pas seulement aux usagers assurément la
city le faire que pouvons nous faire
pour rassurer les chauffeurs les usagers
il faut d'abord d'une prise de
conscience des uns et des autres dans
cette société où le coup de gueule et un
style de façon permanente en
intraveineuse
la haine et la violence dans la société
martiniquaise
le conducteur du bus est le premier qui
prend dès le matin et jusqu'au soir
parce qu'en fait il est le plus proche
le plus accessible
des représentants de l'organisation de
la société organisée il y aura d'autres
incidents de ce genre ces statistiques
mais c'est surtout cercle vicieux décrit
notamment par les syndicats pas
d'investissements pour réparer pour
moderniser les bus des 60 lignes du
réseau
les usagers qui ne sont pas contents des
usagers qui rechignent
archilla payer le ticket de 0,25 qui
sont agressifs ils le manifestent et
puis ce droit de retrait qui est devenu
abbas contrat j'étais le plus facilement
vous l'avez dit fort justement le chien
qui se mord la queue dès lors que les
usagers ne paye pas le ticket d'ailleurs
ce sont plus sûrement ceux qui ne payent
pas le tic qui agressent et donc dès
lors qu'ils ne payent pas le ticket
alors que le ticket ne représentent
qu'eux-mêmes pav 30 % du coût du
transport organisé dès lors qu'ils ne
payent pas alors il devient agresseurs
alors imaginez la suite et des
transferts et comme ça se fait ailleurs
dès lors qu'ils ne payent pas il génère
cette violence est dès lors qu'il gênait
à cette violence points dès lors qu'ils
génèrent ce manque à gagner de
l'entreprise parce que nous sommes dans
le cadre d'une délégation de service
public ou en réalité l'entreprise et les
entreprises se sont engagées sur une
recette est dès lors que cette recette
ne vient pas et bien les investissements
ont du mal à l'art est engagé la
prévenue de la ville agitée du transport
public on peux pas l'envisager pour
peut-être réduire ce fléau d'autres
villes le font alors moi je vais vous
dire le transport est organisé et c'est
vrai que l'on entend beaucoup de gens
s'exprimer parler de déficit
en fait on est encore et payer le
transport est payé sur deux modes
principalement la contribution de
l'usager c'est à dire le prix du ticket
20h25 lot 1 0 25
aujourd'hui le ticket et la contribution
porté par la collectivité qui est donc
là qui sont dans les deniers publics
l'argent des impôts
ce sont les deux moyens de financer le
transport et pour l'organiser et donc
oui il ya des possibilités de voir
autrement mais cela ne dépend pas et
n'est pas une solution que l'entreprise
les entreprises peuvent adopter alors
nous ne sommes pas autorité
organisatrice
alors lorsqu'on sait que les villes qui
composent la cacem saint-joseph hors de
france et celle cher lamentin
la communauté d'agglo la cacem plus la
collectivité territoriale de martinez
qui réussit quand même à mettre de
l'argent frais 9dans dans l'agencé à
petit dans cette cité u
comment on va faire d'autant plus que
vous êtes amené à avoir un joue un rôle
prépondérant dans la gestion de
l'organisation du tcsp si vous n'êtes
pas capable de faire ça avec la
certitude et ça fonctionne comment ça
fonctionnera mieux avec des tcsp alors
vous savez et vous live le dit fort
justement que la cft yeux est un outil
qui a été conçu c'est l'outil des
pouvoirs publics pour pouvoir gérer
cette question difficile du transport de
l'organisation du transport
en fait c'est une société d'économie
mixte qui n'a donc pas vocation à faire
du bénéfice qui a vocation à répondre
justement est précisément aux commandes
de l'autorité organisatrice et donc il
va de soi que des décisions doivent être
prises ailleurs que au sein de la
structure et la sculpture cft humer les
autres entreprises parce que dans le
réseau mozaik il y à pas moins de douze
entreprises qui travaillent au service
du public au service des usagers
alors on s'est lui même les sous
traitants il ya les co traitants c'est
difficile à comprendre de vue de
l'extérieur c'est très simple c'est très
simple nous sommes une entreprise au
sein duquel les pouvoirs publics ville
de fort-de-france kacem demain qui siège
il ya une société privée mais qu'il
société leurs prix devait simplement une
société privée au sein de laquelle
l'état à ses intérêts au travers de la
caisse des dépôts et des consignations
est donc là c'est une société qui a été
mise en place dans l'intérêt de répondre
aux besoins du des usagers et puis
derrière il y à des entreprises qui
l'ont accompagné dans la réponse à la
délégation de service public qui se sont
engagés pour un sur une recette laquelle
recettes ne vient pas des loques le
l'usager ne paye pas nous sommes le 21
février
allal fred aujourd'hui quelle est la
situation précise financièrement de la
cft déficit oui ou non déficit de
combien alors là c'est foutu n'est pas
déficitaire sur l'année 2016
la cft u n'est pas déficitaire sur
l'année 2010 est la cpu a engrangé un
certain nombre de manques à gagner lié
notamment au manque de recettes due à la
fraude massive qui existe sur un réseau
urbain tel que celui de la casse est lié
à une perte de démographie est
déficitaire mais il y a un manque à
gagner
mais la situation entre le précise
yvonne et qui est dans la poche de là
c'est la situation précis que les
déficits antérieurs des années
antérieures depuis 2013 cette situation
pèse lourdement sur lourdement sur la
situation
ils ce sont les deux roues alors nous
avons une situation
les capitaux des fonds propres qu'il
nous faut recapitaliser à hauteur de
deux millions et demi d'euros environ et
donc il nous appartient de avec nos
actionnaires de trouver les solutions
des solutions en interne sur des moyens
propres à la cpu mais les solutions avec
nos actionnaires
ceci est une situation comptable parce
que notamment mais les part nous sommes
n'est pas nous être son frère besson et
sans comprendre que cette situation et
comptable d'abord parce que nous sommes
en train de construire un centre
technique du transport dont la
bénéficiaire final l autorité délégante
ou un centre technique qui a valeur de
24 millions d'euros
nous avions eu une approche en
défiscalisation à hauteur de 5 millions
d'euros laquelle défiscalisation est
encore pendante
en tous les cas été refusé dans sa
première formulation et s'il est là
l'introduction de cette défiscalisation
à haute valeur de 5 millions d'euros à
hauteur du droit les concédants c'est à
dire en dette par rapport à l'autre la
fed élégante qui nous met en situation
ces tables financières et comptables
difficile et c'est là que je vous dis
que vous m'embrouiller parce que moi je
veux bien là maintenant à la place de
l'usager du martiniquais du contribuable
comme vous dites
ce sont des explications très techniques
très comptable je veux bien aller soit
très sain ça renvoie surtout l'image du
nez cas pas celle d'une incapacité de la
part de technicité des pouvoirs publics
d'organiser quelque chose de tellement
primordial pour les martiniquaises avoir
une capacité de pouvoir se déplacer
tranquillement librement sereinement
talent dans ce pays de mille kilomètres
seulement ce que l'usager ce que le
contribuable est unique et doit
comprendre c'est que la crt eut fait et
a toujours fait tout ce qu'il faut pour
répondre aux injonctions des autorités
délégantes des autorités organisatrices
du transport jusqu'à y compris à
s'engager dans la construction d'un
centre technique dont l'accepter n'est
pas le bénéficiaire final au travers de
toutes sortes de techniques et
aujourd'hui les déficits dont on parle
ne sont pas les déficits de la série ce
sont le déficit de l'autorité qui va
bénéficier des des infrastructures qui
sont mises en place on a eu en fait
n'est que l'outil à travers duquel on
agit dans l'intérêt des usagers alors
bien sûr le transport ça a un coût vous
l'avez dit vous-même ce coup il est
financé soit pratiqué le 10 soit par les
dotations habilitations donc on doit
tirer toutes les conclusions si on veut
le centre technique si on veut des
transports organisés faire l'accolade à
ses moyens pour réfléchir à la question
le lui les enjeux pour la cft pour le
réseau nous et qui peut-être même pour
leur semble
du transport public à la martinique
c'est cette perte démographique ce
vieillissement de la population
est ce que vous y pensez mais bien sûr
cela pèse sur les comptes de la cftc
bien simple nous avions fait un compte
d'exploitation prévisionnel qui
prévoyait une recette
une recette qui était à un montant donné
et je voulais dit le ticket n'étant pas
payés par cause pour cause de fraude
mais aussi pour cause de changement de
la courbe démographique
parce qu'en réalité nous avons une perte
de population et donc les prévisions ne
sont plus les mêmes places que nous
avons répondu à les délégations de
service public
la prévision disait 410 mille habitants
à l'orée de 2015 2016
aujourd'hui nous sommes réticents à
cette simulation et est en train de
vieillir ça fait dix ans qu'on sait
qu'on perd temps d'un monsieur chaque
année ça veut dire que les dirigeants de
la cft eu d autres réseaux de transports
publics à la martinique et même les élus
ne savent pas tenir compte de ce genre
de musique ils ont tenu compte de 7-2 et
les piscénois d'hôpital a jadis que
puisque je vous ai dit d'entrée de jeu
que la cft il n'est pas déficitaire en
2016 n'est pas déficitaire en 2017
c'est parce que il y a eu ce qu'on
appelle une revoyure c'est à dire que la
cft eu au titre de des entreprises du gm
du groupement d'entreprises mosaïque a
revu son autorité délégante pour tenir
compte de ces modifications de ces
changements qui sont intervenus et donc
la la la la collectivité l'autorité
délégante à l'époque à réajuster son sa
contribution par rapport à ces réalités
quand l'entreprise que les entreprises
n'ont pas à subir n'ont pas à porter sur
leurs épaules puisque en fait nous
sommes dans un service public qui fait
pour le compte de
merci d'abord est avec nous ce matin là
le frédo rappelle que vous êtes
président de la cftc merci de votre est
revenu dans son crédit bonne journée
merci aux auditeurs et avoue même merci
à martinique 1ère d'aborder les choses
difficiles